sau năm tháng đầu dịch II, tổng thống đơn anh Trump cho thấy tổng đồ hiện thức
quá cầm kết chính cử vượt dựa vãn. Đá lột gí thiêu bán ím bốn trăm tỷ đồ
lắm ý vừa được ký, là một trong nhiều giống móc cho thấy quy tâm định hình
lại chính xích thế, nhập cơ và an xin sả hội của ông. Đồng thời toán tôi cao
với nhiều cơ quan hành phát, đang tựng bất tạo thật lời cho tổng thống mở giọng
quy lực điều hành. Chên mà chẳng đối ngoại, chỉ là cướng sang tự ý vãn yêu cộng
tổ tăng chi tự cua phòng và sư lại các cầm kết thường mại, tự tổng thống đình chính xác
nước Mỹ trên hết, mà tổng thống trong theo đổi, dù vậy, với tăng tuy nhiệp khẩu và cất sạm
hình xe cu tế, khó thể ăn hưởng đến xúc mạnh mềm của Mỹ. Vậy đối nổi, chế dịch
xin nhập cơ và cải tổ sáng dục đang tầy chính kánh, đã bia trưng bất cả những
chừng đẹp đối mặt ritor suy sạm chất lượng và tụi nhân tài. Bây lưu trọn chụi tình
và lựa chờ phép cũng sẽ lửa bước mọi quan trọng, có thể đã đồng đến thiệt trường tài chính và chính
sức tình tệ lâu sài. Bình cảnh những thẳng lượng đáng kể, tổng thống tròm vẫn về đối mặt với các
suy só kinh tế và bài toàn đủ hộ cử chi, đã bia trưng mới cảnh một bộ phận dân chúng tao ra
lòng ngày, chừng những thay đổi quá nhăn và sâu sợ.